en sixième position des chroniqueurs
vous avez voté chez vous on rappelle le
le classement Guillaume Mathieu Raymond
Béatrice Jean-Marie 6e position
Géraldine et 6e avec
bravo en fait jusqu'à la 10e place c'est
bon parce que c'est il y a 10 personnes
à table après c'est que
vous êtes sympa les gens vous préférez
chez vous
ça tient la position
position c'est une fille
tu es une fille
non
[Rires]
neuvième position
c'est Bernard Montiel
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
quand je vais donner la personne qui 11e
vous avez bien sûr trouver chez ici qui
sont les deux derniers
qu'on sera pas premier rappelez-vous
Céline Dion les derniers sont les
premiers s'il te plaît
si j'étais toi problématiques
[Rires]
je vais dire
je vais annoncer celle qui est dernière
de la classe on passe celle qui est 11e
toi tu es toi ou toi tu serais comme la
première dauphine on s'en fout toi
ton premier au dernier de toute façon
au milieu
tu as bien compris le principe
[Rires]
celle qui est dernière de la classe
en compagnie de Benjamin Castaldi
c'est une légende
une légende du sexe
mais également de la télévision
elle a son actif plus de
65 ans de télévision
elle s'habille bien alors
elle aime la vie
pour l'instant ça marche pour les deux
et surtout
elle aime l'amour elle a une très belle
coiffure elle a des cheveux magnifiques
est-ce qu'elle a une belle chatte
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr de l'animal et non pas bien sûr
de l'animal l'animal
la dernière de la classe
ça me fait de la peine
Daniel Daniel Benaim ou capable de
lancer chez vous que Benjamin Castaldi
et dernier de la classe c'est sûr
comme souvent il est accompagné
on se quitte jamais avec Benjamin alors
les chéris merci d'avoir participé
l'important c'est d'être là
et je vais vous dire moi vous n'êtes pas
dernier dans mon classement on est avant
dernier avant dernier